bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur 124 notre invité aujourd'hui et
petro porochenko il a été président de
l'ukraine entre 2014 et 2019 et il est
avec nous depuis kiev la capitale de
l'ukraine
merci d'être avec nous merci beaucoup je
sais prochain coup vous revenez juste
czerny rives czerny jc la plus grande
ville libérée par les forces chrétiennes
d'un siège russe qui a duré plusieurs
semaines
c'est à 150 kilomètres au nord de kiev
près de la frontière avec la russie avec
la biélorussie également
et donc après ce qui a été découvert à
bord awdian cas après ce qui a été
découvert notamment à bout de chat
est-ce que vous avez constaté des choses
similaires des crimes similaires
devrais-je dire à tenerife chez edf
les tragédies ne sont jamais exactement
les mêmes
la tragédie de lucha c'est un symbole
des mâts chaque
effectué par les troupes russes
dans cette région la fraîche de mariée
paul la tragédie n'a rien qu'à la
tragédie du costa mal la tragédie de
balzac la tragédie de la peine la
tragédie de tiers nega
c'est une tragédie pour le monde entier
qui est effectué par ses troupes ces
barbares us le problème c'est qu'ils
s'exécutent des civils ils violent les
femmes
devant leurs enfants
il assassine sans aucune explication des
personnes âgées et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on pourra jamais oublier et
ceux qui ont participé à ce massacre ne
pourront pas l'oublier non plus
aujourd'hui notre initiative consiste à
identifier
ces criminels qu'on a reconnu qu'on a
identifié
lors de ces exactions
il faut créer une liste comme la liste
de mcnish qui il faut créer une liste de
boudhha liste de borodianka liste de
czernin guînes
en tout cas une douce de boudhha
et ces criminels doivent être poursuivis
ils doivent être punis de manière à ce
que ça ne se reproduise jamais ce genre
de tragédies
nous allons une coordonnées avec nos
partenaires européens y compris les
français avec nos partenaires américains
nous avons grâce à eux des technologies
qui permettent d'identifier les visages
de ces criminels qui ont exécuté des
civils qui ont tamedia se catastrophe
lutter contre le génocide des ukrainiens
c'est exactement ce qu'ils font du fonds
un génocide
et je crois que
punir ces barbares les sanctions
internationales avant ces barbaries et
après cette barbarie de ces sanctions
devraient être différentes
la guerre continue mais la nature de
cette guerre la nature même à évoluer et
ces sanctions doivent être encore plus
dur puis ferme
et la liste de butch à la liste de ces
criminels des criminels qu'on doit
poursuivre selon le droit international
dans des tribunaux ukrainiens dans des
congés craignait parce que c'est ici que
les crimes ont eu lieu contre les
ukrainiens
je suis convaincu qu'il faut rejeter la
russie de ce conseil international des
droits de l'homme
car ils sont plus qualifiées pour parler
des droits de l'homme après ces
exactions
je demande aux partenaires
internationaux de l'ukraine de revenir
en ukraine et votre présence à bout de
chatière négatif à gaston mayila baronne
janka
cette présence sera un symbole de
solidarité avec l'ukraine
nous essayons d'expliquer ce qui se
passe et pourquoi on ne peut pas se
permettre de compromis avec la russie
après bitchin
parce que poutine veut tous nous tu fais
et nous nous voulons vivre
toutes il veut évacuer la carte du monde
et nous nous voulons vivre dans ce pays
qui a plus de mille ans d'histoire
notre pays et dans les circonstances
actuelles il est aussi possible d'avoir
un compromis avec le diable entre le
diable et la société qui mène normale ce
week-end avec un avenir
monsieur prochain j'ai bien écouté ce
que vous avez dit vous l'avez dit façon
assez émotionnel cela veut dire qu'il ne
peut y avoir aucune discussion avec
vladimir poutine et pourtant c'est
exactement ce que l'administration est
jeune ce qu'ils essayent de faire il
essaye de parler aux russes et de
négocier vous dites on ne négocie pas
avec le diable
écoutez j'ai une expérience de 5 ans
négociations avec poutine
ce qu'il ne faut pas évoqué c'est une
amnistie pour ces criminels qui ont
effectué ces exactions à bout de chat on
ne peut pas en parler on peut pas
promettre une amnestie assez barbare
et qui ont effectué ces élections dans
différentes villes de l'ukraine
d'ailleurs personne au monde il n'est
plus amoureux de la paix que les
ukrainiens donc il faut forcer poutine a
accepté la paix alors le premier point a
évoqué un chien sécher le feu
inconditionnel
sans aucun préliminaire il faut arrêter
de tuer des ukrainiens il faut arrêter
ces tueries point numéro 2 retrait des
troupes russes point numéro trois
retraits de l'artillerie et des armes
et puis on pourra parler des principes
de sécurité européenne et des principes
de sécurité mondiale
mais en même temps on ne peut pas mettre
en cause d'or de négociation de l'or de
compromis l'intégrité
territoriale l'indépendance et la
souveraineté de l'ukraine
parce que je peux vous dire une chose si
en 2008 lors du sommet de bucarest le
plan d'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'otan
avait été acceptée et chine en 2013 ou
2014 l'ukraine avait été acceptée de
plain pied au sein de l'otan il n'aurait
pas eu d'agression une crime est par
l'agression dont basse et pas de
véritable guerre contre l'ukraine mais
ce précieux pour chaque qu est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que les russes
ont abandonné le nord de l'ukraine et
kiev et qu'il se concentre sur l'est sur
le dindon basse dont vous venez parler
est-ce que vous pensez que vladimir
poutine veut une partition de l'ukraine
sûrement pas parce que
je suis fier
en tant que président à l'époque en tant
que chef des armées
de 2014 19 ce mois ci en place les
forces armées et cette nouvelle armée au
niveau de l'otan a arrêté les troupes us
et les a repoussés en dehors du kef
ils ont compris qu'ils ne pouvaient plus
tenir ce franc sur deux mille kilomètres
contre les frères du craignaient
ils ont décidé de se battre contre les
femmes ukrainiennes contre les enfants
ukrainiens et contrer les personnes
âgées ukrainienne dans un tel contexte
c'est les parts poutine qui a décidé de
retirer ses troupes de caisse ses
troupes étaient sur le point d'être
encerclés par l'armée
donc il a protégé ses troupes en les
ramenant à mais la russie un pays
qui participent à l'agression contre le
chêne et il va les envoyer au donbass
mais vous le dire très clairement que
nous n'abandonnerons jamais
mais
va poursuivre ses agressions
et il a parlé de désescalade mais ça
c'est une désescalade à la poutine ce
sont des mots ce ne sont pas des actes
et dans ce cadre nous à kiev nous allons
continuer de nous préparer à lutter pour
défendre kef
contre cette route ruche
nous devons être vigilants
et ne pas permettre à poutine de
détruire kiev ou de détruire l'ukraine
et nous sommes prêts nous sommes prêts à
l'affronter affronter la russie très
rapidement parce que nous n'avons
presque plus de temps le sénat américain
vient d'adopter à l'unanimité
une procédure dite de prêt bail qui
permettra d'acheminer plus rapidement
des équipements militaires à l'ukraine
la chambre des représentants doit encore
l'approuver mais c'est une formalité
est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut être
un tournant décisif pour l'ukraine et
son objectif de s'armer avec les
équipements militaires dont elle estime
avoir besoin
une guerre se construit au sénateur
américain qui dit merci au gouvernement
et au président raiden il s'agit de la
mise en oeuvre de mon plan en cinq
étapes que j'ai proposé il ya cinq
semaines point numéro un
le projet de loi après bye armes et
denrées alimentaires
point numéro 2 un deuxième front des
sanctions un embargo il faut que ça soit
dirigée contre eux poutine soit numéro 3
la liste du cha point numéro 4
la perspective européenne pour l'ukraine
et point numéro 5 un plan marshall
d'ailleurs nos partenaires européens ont
été très encourageants concernant le
plan marshall
et je demande à nos amis français au
peuple français faites comme les
américains comme le sénat américain a
adopté un projet de loi prevail du côté
français c'est très important
petro porochenko merci beaucoup d'avoir
accordé cet entretien à france 24 depuis
les rues de kiev et merci à vous d'avoir
regardé cet entretien sur nos antennes
en fin de son iphone
[Musique]